Burke will call the roll president if
there was ever a time in the modern
history of America that the American
people become engaged in what's going on
here in Washington now is that time
decisions are being made as we speak
which will impact not only our
generation but the lives of our children
and our grandchildren or for decades to
come and I fear very much that the
decisions are being contemplated are not
good decisions are not fair decisions
right now there is a lot of discussion
about two things number one the
importance of the United States not
defaulting for the first time in our
history on our debts and I think there
is increased understanding that that
would be a disaster for the American
economy that would be a disaster for the
world's economy and we should not do
that but secondly there is increased
discussion now on long-term deficit
reduction how we address the crisis
which we face today of a record-breaking
deficit 1.4 trillion and a 14 plus
trillion dollar national debt a debt by
the way that was caused by two unpaid
wars huge tax breaks for the wealthiest
people in this country a Medicare Part D
prescription drug program written by the
insurance company and the lack of
revenues coming in because of a
recession caused by the greed and
recklessness and illegal behavior on
Wall Street I'll be that as it may
regardless of how we got to where we are
right now there are efforts to develop
long-term deficit reduction plants and
one of them has to do with a so-called a
gang of six and while we do not know all
of the details of that proposal in fact
we never will because a lot of that
proposal our boots the issue to
committees like the Finance Committee
you have to work out the details and
can know what those details will be at
this time I think it is fair to say that
Senator Coburn senator Crapo and Senator
Chambliss deserve a word of
congratulations clearly they have won
this debate in a very very significant
way my guess is that they will probably
get eighty or ninety percent of what
they wanted in this town that is quite
an achievement are they have stood firm
and a desire to represent the wealthy
and the powerful and multinational
corporations they have threatened they
have been are very smart in a number of
ways they have been determined and at
the end of the day they will get eighty
or ninety percent of what they want that
is their victory and I congratulate them
on their victory unfortunately their
victory will be a disaster for working
families in this country for the elderly
for the sick for the children and for
low-income people and I did want to
mention based on the limited information
that we have and as I get more
information I will be on the floor more
often but I think it is important to at
least highlight some of what is in this
so-called Gang of Six are that the
corporate media among others is
enthralled about some may remember that
for a number of years leading Democrats
said that we will do everything that we
can to protect Social Security that
Social Security has been an
extraordinary success in our country
there for 75 years with such volatility
in the economy social security has paid
out every nickel owed to every eligible
American and I've heard Democrats say
that Social Security has nothing to do
with the deficit and that is right
because Social Security is funded by the
payroll tax not by the US Treasury
Social Security has a two point six
trillion dollar surplus today can pay
out every bed
owed to every eligible American for the
next 25 years an enormously popular
program poll after poll from the
American people says don't cut social
security two and a half years ago when
Barack Obama then senator from Illinois
ran for president of the United States
he made it very clear if you vote for
him no cuts in Social Security and yet
what senators Coburn crapo and Chambliss
have managed to do in the Gang of Six is
reached an agreement where there will be
major major cuts in Social Security
don't let anybody kid you about this
being some minor thing it is not what we
are talking about is that under this
so-called Gang of Six proposal Social
Security cuts would go into effect by
the year 2012 virtually immediately and
what that means is that 10 years from
now the typical 75 year old person will
see their social security benefits cut
by five hundred and sixty dollars a year
and the average 85 year old will see a
cut of one thousand dollars a year now
for some people here in Washington maybe
the big lobbyists to make hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year five hundred
and sixty bucks a year or a thousand
asya may not seem like a lot of money
but if you are a senior trying to get by
on 14 15 18 thousand dollars a year and
you're 85 years old the end of your life
you're totally vulnerable you're sick a
thousand dollars a year cut and what
you're otherwise would have received is
a major major blow so I congratulate
senator Coburn senator Crapo senator
Chambliss for doing what President Obama
said would not happen under his watch
what the Democrats have said would not
happen under their watch major cuts in
social security but it's not just social
security we have 50 million American
today who have no health insurance at
all under the Gang of Six proposal there
will be cuts in Medicare over a ten-year
period of almost 300 billion dollars
there will be massive cuts in Medicaid
and other health care programs there
will be caps on spending which mean that
there will be major cuts in education if
you are a working-class family hoping
that you're going to be able and that
you'll be eligible for a pell grant
think twice about that because that pell
grant may not be there if you're a
senior who relies on a nutrition program
that nutrition program may not be there
if you think it's a good idea that we
enforce clean air and clean water
provisions so that our kids can be
healthy those provisions may not be
there because they'll be major cuts in
Environmental Protection now I have
heard some people say well you know all
that's not so good but at least finally
our Republican friends are saying we
need revenue and we're going to Gary use
a billion dollars in revenue well mr.
president let me ask you this if you
read the outline of the Gang of Six
proposal which is admittedly big I think
they would acknowledge that they don't
have all the details there are very very
clear provisions making sure that we are
going to make massive cuts in programs
for working families for the elderly for
the children those cuts are written in
black and white what about the revenue
well it's kind of a kind of a the
projection is that maybe we will raise
over a ten-year period a hundred billion
dollars in revenue where is that coming
from is it necessarily going to come
from the wealthiest people in this
country is it going to come from large
corporations who are enjoying huge tax
breaks mr. president that is not clear
at all and what happens if we don't
reach that revenue of a trillion dollars
what
Judaism is in place to say that it
happens that mechanism in fact does not
exist at all what we do know and we know
you know in fairness and I think the the
authors of this proposal would
acknowledge this is not all the details
are out there but certainly I want
middle class families to understand that
when we talk about increased revenues
you know where that come from that may
come from where it may come from it may
come from cutbacks and the home mortgage
interest deduction program which is so
very important to millions and millions
of families it may mean that if you have
a health care program today that health
care program may be taxed that's a way
to raise revenue it may be that there
will be increased taxes on your
retirement programs your IRAs your 401ks
but we don't have the details for that
all we have is some kind of vague
promise that we're going to raise a
trillion dollars over the next ten years
no enforcement mechanism and no clarity
as to where that revenue will come from
so mr. president I think that it is
terribly important that the American
people become engaged in this debate
which will have a huge impact not only
on them on their parents and on their
children and I believe very strongly
that what the American people must fight
for is not a big deal or a small deal
but a fair deal at a time when the
wealthiest people in this country are
doing phenomenally well and their
effective tax rate is the lowest on
record at a time when the top 400
individuals in this country own more
wealth than 150 million Americans at a
time when corporate profits are soaring
and in many instances corporations these
same corporations pay nothing in taxes
at a time when we have tripled military
spending
since 1997 there are fair ways to move
toward deficit reduction which do not
slash programs that working families and
children and the elderly desperately
depend upon so mr. president I feel that
the issue we're dealing with is of
enormous consequence it is clear our
Republican friends have succeeded and I
congratulate them on getting eighty
ninety percent of what they wanted I
would like people to think back three
years ago just three years ago to think
that there would be a serious proposal
on the floor of the Senate with all of
these devastating cuts I think very few
people would have thought that possible
so I congratulate my Republican
colleagues for their apparent victory
but this senator is going to fight back
I was not elected to the United States
Senate to make devastating cuts in
Social Security in Medicare and Medicaid
in children's programs while I lower tax
rates for the wealthiest people in this
country that's not what I was elected to
do and I do not intend to do that so mr.
president I hope the American people get
engaged in this issue stand up and
demand that the United States Congress
pass a fair and responsible deficit
reduction program not what we are
talking